paul i want you to imagine that you are
a coach in a room full
of young indie filmmakers who are fed up
and they're ready to call it quits
okay and so it's your job to deliver
a half-time speech oh my god
that will forever shape these indelible
minds
these their filmmaking careers and these
these young you didn't ask gary king
this question unstable minds
i want you to be as animated and as
full of life as you need to be oh my
gosh so you were rising these guys
you want me to win one you want my
gipper speech there you go
super bowl was yesterday oh yeah and
denver lost that's that was my team
but see here you are like imagine
you know just get your head out of your
asses boys like there you go
so you know why i say that you don't
remember why you got into this did you
get into this for the glory did you get
did you just make money you want to if
you get into filmmaking to make money
you're the stupidest ever
because film making is the worst
most inconsistent way to make money you
get into this thing to make movies it is
a privilege
to make movies why do we make movies
because we love
making movies that's what quentin
tarantino says in a set when their
things are hard to move and stuff around
they go
what do we love we love making movies
you know here's some my um i was on
on 10 till noon we were uh we ran we had
an actor that was a problem
another actor that couldn't remember
their lines we had we were over budget
the dp was
uh way too slow we were going to have
attitudes to the schedule we didn't know
where the money was going to come from
our first id was all over the map we're
going to fire him and replace a
mid-shoot and i came home and i was
loading all this stuff on my ex-wife my
wife at the time my ex-wife now
and learning all this stuff and she goes
enjoy this
like what do you mean she's like when's
the next time you're going to have the
privilege of having these problems
enjoy this you have a film you can't get
into festivals
let's look at that sentence you have a
film you made a film
do something with it make the next film
take what you're going to go to the next
one you
make movies because you like making
movies if there's any other reward in it
don't do it if you don't like making
films if you're not compelled to make
films
don't make films if you are do that and
enjoy doing that thank goodness for
digital technology
and the 5d and iphones
and road mics and and final cut pro and
final cut x and whatever else because
you can do them
very anybody can make a film now it's
like owning a typewriter or being a
novelist you want to write novels
write novels published or not you want
to make films
stop worrying about the festival stop
worrying about the industry
worst thing ever for art and just make
movies
there's your gipper speech